everybody is Charlie this is gonna be my
arrow Battle Royale episode hopefully
they win an award for the stunts and the
camerawork they did in this because they
did say it was one of their most
ambitious attempts that they've ever
tried on the show they also clear the
path for the crossover episode even
though next week is just a regular
episode getting back to basics before
the big crossover episode so I'll remind
everybody about the schedule at the end
of the video - there's a new round of
that iMac sticky giveaway all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber and
write your favorite fight from the
episode on the video so top 10 WTF and
Easter eggs starting with number 10 Diaz
gets into slaps side just as Oliver's
getting out sort of setting the stage
for their daredevil style prison fight
episode the episode was kind of like
them doing their version of The Punisher
prison fight from daredevil season 2 if
they cross that with the daredevil
hallway fight from daredevil season 3
and just turned those things into an
entire episode so it was like a 42
minute daredevil hallway fight I feel
like it worked they did a pretty good
job with it
9 Oliver vows to make his little
sycophant friend face justice for
framing bronze tiger and doing all kinds
of shady stuff he's proven himself very
untrustworthy the entire season of
course he's legit crazy he even jacks up
Oliver with sedative later the way the
actors playing it makes it seem like he
is genuinely crazy he's not just trying
to lie to Oliver about things that he's
done that are terrible like he genuinely
believes like he hasn't done anything
wrong
like a real crazy person would haven't
really been a big fan of him this season
but I feel like this episode redeemed
him and set him up for a cool arc in the
back half of the season eight Oliver
tries to make good with bronze Tiger
vowing to help him get out with Argus's
help maybe setting him up for a cool arc
in the back half of the season they make
it pretty clear that they're not best
buds or anything like that but I think
that they could have a working
arrangement in the second half of the
season if bronze tiger does get early
release their scenes together felt like
they worked really well as a pair so
sometimes it can be a lot of fun to pair
Oliver up with people that aren't Diggle
or natural team arrow people because the
future of team arrow is kind of up in
the air and then we also have the backup
Green Arrow that we still have not
unmasked yet even though we
know who that is we don't need to get
into spoilers for that person on this
video but we'll be talking more about
them as we start the second half of the
season in January so no worries about
that 7d as surprising Oliver with the
visitation in pissing him off so much
that he tried to beat his way through
the plexiglass on the day he's supposed
to get early release
it's just Diaz trying to lay it on thick
that's his big thing like everybody that
goes after Oliver has tried to get him
worked up to lose his [ __ ]
the look on stephen amell face when he's
doing this is great too like he's not
screaming or anything like that he has a
very calm murdery looking face while
he's trying to get to die' ass through
the glass it was a nice touch having
Diaz killed that guard after forcing him
to say Oliver Queen you have failed this
city they have to work it into every
episode like this it would be weird if
they didn't do that six
Oliver macgyvering his way out of his
cell we knew they had to do it at some
point this season and he's genuinely
smarter than he comes off a lot in
episodes they write him usually in
scenes to allow other characters to give
him explainers especially if Felicity is
around usually he'll just wait for her
to explain some technical thing and make
it seem like he doesn't understand when
really he probably does but this is the
beginning of the daredevil hallway fight
that lasts for pretty much the rest of
the episode where he has to beat his way
through the guards but then later save
them because they don't buy any of this
Diaz business he's trying to sell him
like look you need to call for backup
now no way this prison it's the most
secure prison in the world five they pay
off the set up for the bronze tiger when
he saves him from Cody Rhodes and brick
like he's just sitting there on the
floor till he walks up and hands in the
shank even though brick got his own
during the episode
Cody really took it he got stabbed a
couple times in this hallway by Oliver
slashes his femoral artery Lee's not to
do what they do to him later in the
episode so it seems like Cody Rhodes
might be down for the count in terms of
coming back as a guest star on arrow who
knows the rest of the episode is mostly
a series of really big bites though so
for the mess hall fight so they have all
the guards strung up like they're big
cuts of beef at the butcher shop just
beating them senseless Oliver tries to
call them out they set everything on
fire and he finally starts throwing down
with Diaz with his trusty sack of soda
that he's fashioned into a weapon I did
like the way they were trying to be
authentic to the tools that they would
be able to use inside
this prison environment so it's not like
he has access to really advanced weapons
he just has to use what's available to
him Bourne style like beating someone
with a book but because bronze Tigers
with him they do this cool thing with
the camera work while they're fighting
their way through all these other
prisoners in the guards so in that big
hallway area where all the prison cells
are they have this giant crane and they
would just pan around without cutting so
even though the entire fights were not
all continuous shots they did do a lot
of really long takes daredevil hallway
style so when they say that this was
their most ambitious episode it's stuff
like that it's a lot harder to organize
those shots just based on the types of
sets that you shoot on but three they
set Cody Rhodes on fire and throw him
over the balcony and you just see him
twitching there on the ground like is
this the end of him how much more
punishment can he take they've shanked
him so many times this episode but it's
the comic book world so who knows it's
hard to tell unless you see they're
buried in the ground like their skull
separated from their body it's hard to
tell who's dead and who's not - though
was Oliver in Diaz's final fight so they
battle royale up and down the prison on
the third level Oliver gets thrown over
the balcony they're shooting it in that
same way that they were doing the
hallway style fight were they pan around
with the giant crane like it's a big
long continuous shot and even though
Diaz continuously reminds Oliver that
he's jacked up on his special mirakuru
style serum it's not quite like mirakuru
he's not that powerful
but he's still supposed to be way
stronger than he was before like he's
able to kick all of her all the way into
his cell against the wall that's how
strong he is
but Oliver is able to overpower him and
the interesting thing in this year if he
didn't catch it
he actually fights Oliver back into his
former cell that's why they pan on the
number there because it's Oliver's
prisoner number so when Oliver finally
overpowers him it locks him in the cell
he's locking him in his former cell and
remember that was Diaz's whole thing
like he vowed that he was never going to
die in prison but seemingly he is in
prison now so who knows what will happen
with him in the back half of the season
but remember if he's still alive that
means that he's probably going to come
back at some point but my number one WTF
actually goes to Oliver's special buddy
that he's had this entire season
shanking brick while he was trying to
escape through the morgue turns out you
do have to be dead to get out through
the morgue but the thing he says is
actually big setup I think for the back
half
the CSUN way says you should have been
nicer to me and remember as we found out
during the episode confirmed crazy
person so it just feels like him on the
loose is gonna be a big thing for Oliver
in the back half of the season you
should have been nicer to me Green Arrow
and he seems like a strangely
resourceful well-connected person so it
just feels like there's way more story
coming from that character but the whole
thing with next week's episode is that
it's just getting back to basics
Oliver going back on the Green Arrow
beat don't shoot anybody your first week
out of prison good solid tip because the
week after that is gonna be the
crossover episode in the mid-season
finale where he gets to be Barry Allen
for a week morning cakes are perfect
this time so I've already done a trailer
video for the recent Superman black suit
promo it's badass it has pretty much all
the characters in it so I'll add a link
for that at the end of this but just let
me know what you thought of their big
daredevil Punisher hallway fight episode
probably one of my favorite action-heavy
episodes of the series that isn't a big
crossover episode because usually the
crossovers wind up being the biggest
episodes but we got new flash episode
tomorrow click here for that brand new
Elseworlds
trailer and click here for my brand new
Avengers infinity war Thor deleted the
scene video thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight
[Music]